des vélos qui attendent leurs futurs
compagnons de route
voici la vélostation de saint quentin en
yvelines après sept ans d'attentes les
saint quentinois bénéficie désormais
d'un espace pour leur deux roues deux
cent trente emplacements sécurisés
vous avez un lecteur de badge à
l'extérieur on passe le pass navigo et
donc la personne l'utilisateur rentre
son vélo et le stationnent sur les sur
les espaces qui sont prévus à cet
endroit
autre service proposé par la vélostation
la location de vélos il y en a cent
soixante dix ans tout compter 3 euros la
journée pour la location d'un vélo
standard 15 euros par jour pour un vélo
à assistance électrique
enfin un service de maintenance propose
de s'occuper de votre deux roues la
personne prend rendez vous nous
l'accueillons à l'atelier et nous
entretenons réparons le vélo suivant un
forfait près établi pièces et main
d'oeuvre pour des prestations qui vont
de la crevaison
la révision générale du vélo avec ses
400 km d'aménagements cyclables
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'inscrit dans
une démarche de mobilité durable
objectif avec cette vélostation
encourager les usagers de la gare à
utiliser ces transports propres
la part modale d'utilisateurs est encore
relativement peu élevé 2 % mais donc
avec ces nouvelles facilités a déçu on
espère d'affaires passer de 4 à 5 % dont
- la doubler assez prochainement
enfin sachez que se déplacer à vélo est
bon pour l'environnement mais aussi eu
du bon pour la santé
une pratique quotidienne permettrait
d'allonger de cinq ans
l'espérance de vie